[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES FALLOWS: Thank you all
for coming out this afternoon.
Deb and I are really
happy to be here.
We've had connections with
this city for a long time.
In fact, it was 50
years ago right now
in this very city we
met on a blind date,
and we've been together
ever since then.
So we're glad to come back
to where it all started.
We have any family
ties with this company
and its different
incarnations around the world.
One of our sons, Tom, worked
for about four years at Google.
If you've ever seen
Google Shopping Express,
that was his project
when he worked there.
So we're glad to be here
and excited to give you
what we think is a different
message about the country
that we are all living
in now and that will
shape your collective futures.
The way-- we're going
to do this alternating.
I'm going to give a brief intro.
Then Deb will tell
you about something
that she thinks you'll
find surprising.
Then I'll tell you
some more surprises.
Then Deb will have an
additional surprise.
And I'll have the
payoff at the end.
And then we'll have
time for questions.
So we'll go back and
forth for about 25 minutes
and try to leave
you feeling, we hope
better, and at least
indifferent about the condition
of the US and the world.
And the way I thought I'd
introduce what we're doing
is to read a quote
from an editorial
recently in the Bakersfield,
California newspaper.
Who here has been
to Bakersfield?
Those of you who
have been there,
will join me in saying
Bakersfield is not
the Marin County or Santa
Monica of California.
I'm from inland California too.
Bakersfield is sort
of a hard scrabble
place in the southern end
of the Central Valley.
And the editorial in
the Bakersfield paper
last week said "there is
a quietly growing movement
brewing in the
interior of America.
Pretty soon it will
boil over and it's
about time somebody covered it."
We all know that kind of
rhetoric over the past two
years in American discourse,
where the next paragraph has
been people are angry,
people are upset,
people want to tear things down,
people are bitter and divided.
In fact, this was an
editorial in Bakersfield
about the book
and Deb and I have
done and saying that
there is, city by city
across the country, this
sense of reinvention, renewal,
experimentation,
new possibility that
is at such dramatic odds
with the national discourse
that we all are aware of.
So that is the
experience that Deb and I
have had over the last four-plus
years traveling around.
And we'll try to
convince you of it
by the time we are done here.
So let me tell you
just a little bit
about how we
presume to know what
we tell you we know about state
of the United States right now.
I worked for "The Atlantic"
for a very long time.
The magazine is
now 161 years old.
Is that right?
It was founded in 1857.
So that would be more or
less, I think, 161 years old.
I worked for as an employee
for more than one quarter
of its total existence.
And we spent a lot of
that time living overseas.
We've lived China
for a long time.
Deb wrote a wonderful
book about China
called "Dreaming
in Chinese," which
had not the trifecta but
the daily-double of "The New
Yorker" and "Oprah"
both lauded this book.
so we were in China
for a long time.
We were in Japan.
We've been in Malaysia.
And in all these jaunts
around the world,
we have tried to do our best
to get out of the big cities,
to go on trains, on
ox carts, on buses;
however we could to see
the fabric of a country.
And we've been doing that
in China from 12 years ago,
2006 we moved there; off and
on, we came back in 2009,
went again to China
in 2011, and finally
came back from China in 2011.
And the discourse of world
coverage of the US then,
if you remember back, was
the US had led the world
into financial depression.
And the US was finally
reaping the rewards of this.
The US was really falling apart.
So we thought as we
got back to the US,
why not try to apply the same
reportorial approach we'd
had in China, in
Malaysia, in Japan,
and West Africa and
all the rest to the US?
And in our little propeller
plane, who here is a pilot?
Come on.
Who here is a pilot aspirant?
Who here is interested
in the aerial view?
Yeah, OK.
So for a long time we'd been
flying around the country
in our little Cirrus airplane.
Side note, Cirruses are now the
most popular small airplanes
in the world,
single-engine planes,
because they have a parachute
for the entire airplane.
And in time of distress,
there's a little red
handle on the roof of the
cockpit which you pull,
and the entire airplane
comes to the earth
gently with a parachute.
So we've been flying around.
And we knew there were
lots of parts of the US
that you could more easily
get to by small airplane
than you could any other way.
And so we thought
we'd been to places
like Grand Island, Nebraska; and
Rock Springs, Wyoming; and Red
Oak, Iowa and other places of
that sort, what would be like
systematically to look
city by city to see how
the recovery was doing,
what the temper of the times
would turn out to be.
So five years ago in
the spring of 2013,
I put an item on my part of
"The Atlantic" site saying,
tell us why we should
come to your town.
We're looking for
smaller towns by which we
meant things that were usually
presented in a two dimensional
or one dimensional way
in the national media.
They weren't the 3D
full human actors
that you saw from New York
or DC or LA or San Francisco,
but rather people
who were covered
when there was a shooting,
or when there was a tornado,
or when the Iowa
caucuses were happening,
or when there was
some concept piece.
So tell us about a
smaller town that's
not usually in the media that
has had some kind of problem--
factory closing, drought;
you name the problem
and has an interesting
part of its response.
And we'd like to
come here about it.
We got about 1,000 essays on
one of those Google response
forums.
I forget what's--
what's the term for it,
where I ask people some
spreadsheet that auto populate.
We got more than 1,000
essays, people saying here's
why Moline is the
city of the future.
Here's why Yakima, Washington
is a city you should come to.
And over the last, since
from the summer of 2013
until early 2017, we spent about
half our time on the road, city
by city.
You will see that we were in
the far Northeast in Eastport,
Maine; the far Southwest
in Ajo, Arizona.
We were in the Central
Valley of California,
and places with some
really hard times.
And the cumulative
message that we
ended up presenting in
hundreds of web posts
and in some articles
and in this book now
are that the narrative of
America at the cellular level,
or at the organic systems level,
is really different from what
it is at the national level.
And most people feel much
more hopeful, much better,
and much more engaged about
the part of the United States
that they experience
in their direct lives
than they do about the part
that comes through the media.
And the polls reflect this
too with only about 25%
of the public thinks the
US is on the right course,
but about 80% of the public
thinks their own communities
are on the right course now.
And that's been a stable
finding for the past few years.
So this was a journey of
a lot of surprises for us.
And I will tell you about a sort
of checklist of main surprises
and take-homes in just a moment.
But I give you now miss
Deborah Fellows, who
is going to tell you about one
of the central surprises that
is related to a
lot of your work.
DEBORAH FALLOW: Thank you.
JAMES FALLOWS: Deborah?
DEBORAH FALLOW: You
can call me Deb.
When Jim I first
landed in a town
and we would usually stay for
a couple of weeks at a time,
we rounded up the usual
suspects and went out together
on our first day.
We talked to a newspaper
editor, somebody connected
with schools, maybe the
Chamber of Commerce,
the mayor or the city manager.
We'd hang out in brewpubs.
We'd wrangle people on
the streets and on bikes.
And then we would split up after
that and follow their lead.
Jim usually covered political
and economic development kinds
of things, what was the
business of the town.
I would go to a lot of
the social institutions,
like the schools, and the
public libraries, and the YMCAs;
places like that.
I want to tell you
today a little bit
about my favorite
one of all, which
is this thriving
public institution
of the public
libraries in towns.
And this completely
took me off base.
Because the library I grew
up with is a very quiet kind
of intimidating place
where librarians
who are always kind of mean
would shush you and not
allow you to talk.
I can see that a lot
of you are probably
in a next generation
of libraries.
But what I learned
about the libraries
is mainly in three
different categories--
education, technology,
and civic and social life
as a community center.
I'll lead with the
technology, because that's
where you all are.
And as a reality
check, I'm going
to tell you a little story
of what I heard and saw
in the Columbus, Ohio
main public library.
Usually when you walk in, there
are big banks of computers
everywhere, as there
were in this library.
And one of the most
popular things going on
at those computers
is a job search.
So there was a young man
sitting at the computer.
And a librarian had come over
to help him look for a job.
They scrolled all
around, found a couple
of things that seemed likely
and possible, landed on one,
and she drew up the application
for this job on the computer
and said.
You fill it in.
I'll come back in 15
minutes, we'll look it over,
and we'll take it from there.
She went away came
back after 15 minutes.
And he had indeed filled
it in, the application,
but with a marking pen on
the face of the screen.
So that is the degree
of low-end technology
and the challenge for public
libraries in that respect.
On the high end, it's much
more what you would probably
recognize, maker spaces.
In our hometown of Washington
DC at the main public library,
I went on a tour of
the maker spaces.
There was standing room
only, everything from artists
to people doing start-ups, to a
mom who was there with her two
home schooled kids trying
to figure out projects,
and education in
everything from how
to use 3D printers, to laser
cutters, to you name it,
and even stuff like you might
have seen in a family home
basement workshop.
And another interesting
thing is maybe
some of you have started in
libraries, where entrepreneurs
who can't afford a home office
or any kind of office to rent,
will sit day after day in the
same spot at the main reading
room and get their
company going from there,
take a break to take
calls in the garden
or a latte in the shop.
And I asked the librarians,
is this something
that you resent that all these
"young people" as we call you,
are starting companies
in your library?
And they said, absolutely not.
We just hope when
they're successful they
remember where they started and
can come back here and support
us.
So education in libraries,
one of the first things
that directors
will always say is
you've got to see the
children's section.
If there's any extra
money in libraries,
it will go to the
children's section
to try to fill in the gaps
of education that are around
in towns, the preschool
and pre-reading.
If I said, tell me,
what's reading readiness?
And the library
director said, if you've
got a kindergartner going into
school and hand them a book
and he holds it upside down,
there is no reading readiness
there.
So that's that kind of starting
point of where education
is in libraries is
a lot of dedication
to the preschool for kids.
Preschool skills,
it goes all the way
through elementary school,
homework help, special areas
for high schoolers that are
kind of cool so kids want
to hang out there, and adult
literacy which is often
the most popular
program for volunteers,
adults teaching
adults how to read.
In the social and civic
sense, the civic engagement
in libraries is really basic.
It's everything from ESL,
to citizenship courses,
to tax preparation,
to welcoming refugees
in towns as their kind
of first landing spot.
And then there's
the social stuff,
which is really the fun stuff
that goes on with libraries.
At my library, there's
Yoga every Tuesday.
On Saturdays at 4:00 PM in the
main reading room of the DC
Public Library, I walked in.
And there were 70
people doing the tango.
There were the professionals
with music accompaniment.
There were the regulars who were
learning how to do the tango.
And it's all kinds
of lending programs.
In Duluth, Minnesota, there's
a seed lending library,
take your seats.
Plant them in the garden.
Bring them back next.
In Burlington, Vermont,
the kids come in
to borrow snow shovel
equipment on the weekends
to make a little
money shoveling snow.
Take it back.
In my hometown of Vermilion,
Ohio which is on Lake Erie,
you can borrow fishing
poles and go out swimming.
In Denver, you can borrow the
complete backpack and hiking
equipment from libraries
to go hiking there.
So it's the point of all this
is that in towns, in local town
America, the library is really
the institution that is filling
in the gaps that are there
in the way that they can--
in civic, social, educational,
and technological sense.
And so part of what we
really feel strongly about
is to try to get
this message out.
Because so many
librarians I heard
said after explaining all the
things that their libraries
did, said that one
of our problems
is that the libraries are
the best kept secret in town.
And that's a place
they don't want to be.
So Jim's surprise number two.
JAMES FALLOWS: So
Deb was telling you
about libraries as a surprise.
We had assumed.
So how many of you
would have assumed
that libraries are on the way
down, of like Barnes Noble
or whatever?
We've seeing them
as coming back.
Here is a quick list,
just I'll list them
without elaborating very
much, of other things that
were surprising to me
personally that I wouldn't
have guessed five years ago.
I have an article in the
current issue of "The Atlantic"
in which I say that reporting
is the process of learning
what you didn't know
until you showed up.
And these were things that why
I've loved being a reporter
is the things you experienced
by being out there.
So here is a quick
list of things
that we think are lessons
of seeing the country
city by city, and not asking
people about national politics.
The first of them
is particularly
relevant to a place like this.
How many of you started out in--
I'm going to separate
the US into metropolis
and countryside.
So metropolis is Boston, DC, LA.
Countryside is every place else.
How many of you started
out in metropolis?
And how many started
out countryside?
So we have a mixture here.
And those of you who have
come to a place like Cambridge
and Boston, you illustrate
one of the great trends
of American history and
world history, which
is the concentration of
people in these big centers.
Finance in New York, education
and medicine and tech
and Boston, entertainment in
LA; we know the whole drill.
And that, of course, is a very
important ongoing pressure.
We were really struck
again and again
by this sort of reverse osmotic
flow of people who thought
I have had a job in Cambridge.
I do have a job offer in
Seattle or in New York City.
But for me and my family,
the overall life balance
is much better in Fresno, or
in Greenville, or in Duluth,
or in Erie or in a lot
of the other towns we're
talking about for a
combination of reasons that
involve real estate, arbitrage.
There's a dozen cities
in the United States
where your life is
destroyed by real estate
and every place else is cheap.
And so there is that
factor that makes
people think they
can start their lives
and their families
better elsewhere.
There is a sense of
engagement, of being
in a scale of
place where you can
make things happen, as opposed
to just sort of observing
what happens.
There are local ties
of people feeling
that they're imprinted by
the feel of the Midwest,
or the feel of the South, or the
feel of the Pacific Northwest.
But again, our book is presented
as a shaggy chronicle, sort
of a whole earth catalog of
things that are happening
around the country.
But you'll hear stories
of people like you all,
who thought that the
better balance for them
was someplace other
than their metropolis.
A second surprise involved the
political temper of the times.
How many of you have
heard, oh, the nation is
more divided than ever before?
We've all heard that.
It's true in Washington DC.
It's true on cable news.
It's not true of
most of the country
and most of what it does.
And here is the easiest way I
know how to illustrate that.
Have any of you been to
Greenville, South Carolina?
It's a really now economically
and culturally progressive
place.
It has a BMW plant.
A Michelin plant, et cetera,
and a very beautiful downtown.
I assume most of you have been
to Burlington, Vermont, which
is very near here.
Politically these
are opposite cities.
Burlington, home
of Bernie Sanders;
Greenville, home of Trey
Gowdy and Jim DeMint
in South Carolina.
If you didn't know
they were opposite,
you would think they
were the same city.
They work the same way, the
university, with the mayor,
with the downtown organizations.
And if we didn't ask people
about the divisive issues
of national politics, they
didn't usually come up.
And there was sort of
the practical mindedness
that you'd like to
think Americans were
known for was also evident.
Another thing that was
surprising and striking to me
is how widespread
in the country is
the sense of being personally,
culturally, ethnically,
or regionally looked
down on and the effects
that has on how people behave.
And those of us who
are not from New York
can assume that New York
looks down on everything.
But almost everybody else
feels looked down on,
the South by the North, interior
California by the coast,
non-whites by whites, the
farmers from the countryside.
You can have almost
any gradation of this
that you want.
When I was in high school in
Redlands, California, Joan
Didion, a famous
writer wrote a story
about how my hometown was like
the worst place in California.
So this is something that
we had a marker with me.
And in many parts
of the country,
this has been a
motivating force.
Who here has been to
Fresno, California?
Now Fresno in the
Central Valley,
they are aware of not being the
stylish center of California.
So two of their mottoes--
one is a rebranding to Fres-yes.
The other is a new civic
revival program under the label
Unapologetically Fresno.
And that we've seen
that in West Virginia.
We've seen it in
many other places,
in Mississippi where
we spent a lot of time.
We've seen-- I'll just
mention two other things which
were surprising and striking.
We all know about
the dislocation
of industrial workers
over the past generation,
as the giant factories
of a bygone era
have been truly bygone.
What has been
surprising to us is
how the interesting contrary
flow of high schools
and community colleges training
people whose parents worked
in those factories and
don't work there anymore
for the new tech jobs,
skilled tech jobs that
are emerging and are
high demand as welders,
as wind turbine repair
people, and a long other list.
If you go to Western Kansas
now, you see the two competing
industries.
You see the wheat fields
and inside of them,
the wind turbines spreading out
over the wheat fields, which
are a major source of wealth.
That was really,
really interesting.
And finally in the
realm of surprises,
I think almost all of us
would think of city government
as the word call
up hidebound-ness
and out-of-date-ness, and not
being innovative in the way
that a tech company might be.
I would contend that
city government right now
is one of the most innovative
and experimental parts
of American society,
where people are trying
different ways to engage
their citizens to have
tech sensors to inform
them of what they're doing.
And we saw countless
illustrations of that.
So we saw some bad surprises.
We saw opioids as a horrible
scourge to the country now.
We saw the effects of
industrial dislocation.
But we also saw a
lot of surprises
that we had not anticipated.
So now I give you Deb.
Deb is an advanced
linguistic scholar.
And now she has the linguistics
part of the conversation.
DEBORAH FALLOW: Yeah, OK.
Advanced linguistics scholar?
JAMES FALLOWS: Well,
you have a PhD.
Come on.
DEBORAH FALLOW: Part of this was
really a listening tour to me.
I was interested to
hear the regionalisms
versus nationalisms that we
all pick up from the media
and so forth.
And it was round about
Greenville, South Carolina
into our second year, I guess,
that we heard this question
from people.
If you're in a
gathering like this
and you don't know each other,
after you introduce yourself
to each other, you might
start with a second question.
And I was interested in what
that second question would be.
In Greenville,
South Carolina, it
was where do you go to church?
When I first heard it, I was
really kind of taken aback.
Because I thought,
this is personal.
This is intrusive.
Why are you asking
me this question?
What if I don't go to
church, et cetera, et cetera?
And so I started asking and
listening in different places,
what's your second question?
And interestingly, I think in
Boston, it's a version of that.
I heard a lot of people say,
maybe an older generation,
of what's your parish?
In Chicago, it's the
what's your parish.
It doesn't even matter
if you're Catholic.
You know what
parish you live in.
So it's the geographical marker.
Is anybody here--
I'm going to stick my neck out.
Is anybody here from St. Louis?
OK.
Can you tell me what's the
second question in St. Louis?
AUDIENCE: Where did
you go to high school?
DEBORAH FALLOW: Yes, OK.
Great.
It has never failed.
That is absolutely the
second question in St. Louis.
We were in Louisville
last week and the version
of that question, it's not
where did you go to high school.
It's where did you go to school?
Because the assumption
is that that just
means high school and you're
not asking beyond that.
So in DC, of course,
it's where do you work.
Or what do you do, or
who do you work for?
Same thing kind of in New York,
unless you start asking about--
real estate goes up there.
Where do you live?
Like sizing you up in
your socioeconomics.
The what-do-you-do question in
Denver and Burlington actually
means what do you do for
fun, like do you hike?
Do you ski?
Do you snowboard?
What do you do?
LA, how'd you get here?
Well I took the 10 to
the 405, and on and on.
In Minnesota I
learned last week,
it's land of 10,000 lakes.
I'm from Minnesota for 10 years.
What's your lake or
what lake do you go to?
And in Wyoming, no kidding,
well maybe kidding--
did you get your elk yet?
It's like everybody
gets an elk and you
get a badge for your elk.
And so did you get your elk yet?
Atlanta and Seattle, and
I don't know maybe Boston,
the question is,
where are you from?
Because so many people are
there for Seattle, we know why.
Atlanta same thing, and it's
just in ingrained in them.
There are two places where you
dare not ask that question.
One is Alaska, because so many
people relocate to Alaska,
because they want to get
away from their past life
and don't want
anybody interfering.
So everybody knows not to
say where are you from.
Similarly in Hawaii,
on the big island,
you don't say
where are you from.
Because that is a big witness
protection program area.
And it's much too
intrusive to ask that.
So one more, my absolute
favorite is from New Orleans.
And this a bit well,
I'll just say what it is.
I heard two versions of it.
One is, who's your mam.
Who's your mama?
Because everybody in New
Orleans kind of knows
each other and everybody
knows who your daddy is.
But they can't tell from
your name who your mama is.
So who's your mama?
Or the more colloquial version,
how's your mama and them?
Which is the kind of
nice intro to that.
So I am collecting more
of these, if you have them
from your places.
Everybody's got one
and they're kind of
in the currency of the town.
And that's why I have a degree
in Advanced Linguistics, right?
JAMES FALLOWS: A virtue of
having been around Cambridge
when we were long ago is that
Deb was studying linguistics
at what was then
called Radcliffe.
But there was this guy
named Noam Chomsky who
was a linguistics professor
in this part of town
you would come learn from too.
So this is the
two-minute big finish,
where I'm going to tell
you what this all means.
Then we'll have questions.
So suppose you are
thinking right now,
these people are crazy.
They've just been avoiding
the harsh realities of the US
by going to garden spots like
San Bernardino, where we spent
a lot of time, or
northern Mississippi,
or Erie, Pennsylvania,
or other places.
We've been to a lot of
places that are rough,
Charleston, West Virginia.
So if you think this is really
an unrepresentative view
of these past four-plus
years all around the country,
the experiment I would
suggest is over the next year
or so try to go to half a
dozen places you don't know.
And when you get
there, don't ask people
about national politics.
If you ask them,
what about Trump,
it's like turning on CNN.
You just know what
you're going to hear.
But if you ask them,
how about the schools?
Who's moving here?
How are things getting
better or worse?
And not in every place in the US
will things be getting better.
Because over the past
century and a half,
many, many small towns are
just too small to survive.
And we can talk about
more of that later on.
But in many of
the places we were
looking at, these medium sized
places of 20,000, 50,000,
et cetera; things were going
in a positive direction.
So see if you can test your
experiences against ours.
But suppose you think
actually we might be right
and that you're willing
at least to accept
our hypothesis that there
is this historic shift
between national level
dysfunction and bitterness
and an inability to match
the resources of the country
to the needs of the country.
There's a gap between
that and this local level
awareness of practicality,
and experimentation,
and willingness to
compromise, and ability
to make long-term plans.
Suppose you thought that
actually might be true.
What would you do then?
I can tell you what
we intend to do
for the foreseeable
future is I apply
a historical model to this.
When Deb was studying her
linguistics in college,
I was studying
American history, which
is the main thing I've
just tried to read about
and learned about
in the interim.
And it does seem to me
there's a real lesson
to be learned from the
period from 1880 to say 1920,
the original Gilded Age,
the original progressive
and populist and
reform era, in the way
that so many of the dislocations
we're having now, extremes
of sudden new wealth from
sudden new technologies,
people suddenly losing their
traditional livelihood,
political dysfunction,
political corruption,
regional bitterness; all those
things have their precedents
150 years ago or so.
But also you look back and
see all the different people
in all their dispersed
ways who were trying
to create a different country.
You had the people in
the labor union movement,
starting after the Civil War.
You had the women's movement.
You had the African-American
rights movement.
You had immigrant
rights movements.
In almost every big city you
had civic improvement movements,
from Jane Addams onward.
In California you had the
Good Government movement.
You had the
conservation movement,
starting under Teddy
Roosevelt and his peers.
And the collection of those
people working together without
knowing they were pulling in the
same direction for quite a long
time over those decades,
meant that when the temper
of national politics
changed as it finally did,
there was a whole array of
experiments and organizations
and solutions that
have been tried;
ones that have succeeded
and ones that hadn't.
And what Louis Brandeis was
saying about the states being
the laboratories of democracy,
looking back on that time,
really is true when we
think of cities right now.
So we actually think it is
like that era again now.
And there is a real
battle underway
for the soul and
future of the country,
between the poison
that is dripping down
from the national level, which
is what dominates our news,
and all the sources of
experimentation and hope
and new ideas that from
most of the country
in a lot of independent
places are being tried out
and succeeding, city by
city and region by region.
David Brooks of
"The New York Times"
had a column about
two weeks ago,
based on our book saying
the headline of which
was, "The American Renaissance
is Already Underway."
And his point was
not, the nation
doesn't have really
grave problems.
It does.
His point was that many, many
people are already finding ways
to try to use the technologies
of this era to connect people,
the new awareness and
possibility to apply
different solutions.
So we think this struggle
is really underway.
And we hope that when
historians 150 years from now
look back on all
of us in this era,
they'll say that you here with
your technologies and people
we've seen in Mississippi,
and Oregon, and South Dakota,
and people in state houses and
city halls around the country
were like their predecessors
in the earlier progressive era,
figuring out the
solutions that would
make a better country possible.
So that, in brief and rushed
fashion, is our pitch.
You'll find the
stories in the book.
So Deb, would you
please come up here
and choose people to answer
questions or to ask questions?
So, thank you.
That's our pitch.
DEBORAH FALLOW: OK.
AUDIENCE: A question I have is
about something I worry a lot
about and try and spend a lot
of mental energy and time trying
to figure out, is the
separation between what's going
on locally-- and I try to
get very involved in the town
of Arlington where
I live today--
again local politics
and civic engagement
there and national politics.
And I've tried to mix
the two over time.
And they don't blend so well.
They show up to say,
an indivisible meeting,
a resistance meeting.
You say, hey, let's talk
about bridging divides.
With Republicans
and conservatives
it doesn't go over so well.
So these things just
don't mix very well.
But at the same time,
it's hard to justify
focusing on one or the other.
So how do you prevent--
what would you recommend
doing on the civic local level
that kind of insulates
you to some extent
from the national
politics without burying
your head in the sand?
Because these
divisions trickle down,
where it's like we see
divisions in town that
seem to me to come from a
lot of that national level
division seeping into--
these microfactures start
forming between liberals
and progressives
within our community;
not necessarily red
and blue divides,
but similar sorts
of divides where
you stand on certain issues.
So how do you do that locally
without being infected
by the national politics?
JAMES FALLOWS: This
is a hard question
that we've spent a lot
of time thinking about.
And let me give you the current
state of my thoughts on it.
I once worked in
national politics
long ago, before anybody
here was even 10 years away
from existing.
When Jimmy Carter was President,
I worked on his campaign.
I was a speechwriter
in the White House.
And I've stayed observing
national politics since then.
What I have learned
about national politics
is that it's a combination of
things which are foreseeable
and you can have vector
diagrams, and things
that are accidental.
And we're still living with
the effects of Lyndon Johnson
deciding to sign
the Civil Rights Act
or pushing the Civil Rights Act,
50-plus years ago, and the ways
in which that peeled
the white South away
from the Democratic Party.
That is sort of the fundamental
political movement of our time,
making the Republicans
a white-based party.
We're dealing with Supreme Court
rulings on political donations.
We're dealing with
lots of other things.
So those are the
fundamental factors.
At the national level, there are
also things no one can foresee.
I was at the Democratic
Convention in 2004
when Barack Obama made
his keynote address.
People there were saying,
yeah this guy is a comer.
But six months
before that, nobody
would have imagined Obama
becoming the president in 2008
and things of that sort.
In 1988 when we were living
in Japan, through sort
of the accidents
of media intensity,
Gary Hart went from being
the likely next President
to having to leave the race,
for accidental factors.
The races of 2000
and 2016 turned out
the way they did for
1,000 dominoes pointing
in a certain direction.
So the reason I'm saying this
is similarly with Jimmy--
I'll go back to Jimmy Carter.
He was elected in the
fall of 1976 comfortably.
Two years before
that, nobody would
have imagined that he
would have ended up
as President, as a former
one-term governor of Georgia.
And there are times in which
the mood of the country
changes in a way that makes
a certain person the voice
of that mood, as
happened to Carter,
as happened to
Obama and arguably
has happened with Trump.
So to lead this to
the local, I think
the next step is
to do everything
one can locally, so as to make
the mood of the country, such
that a person whom we
can't foresee right now
ends up two years from now,
six years from now being
the voice of that sentiment.
Whether it is a Democrat,
you can list a dozen of them;
or whether it's a Republican,
you list one or two of them;
who would seem to be the voice
of what people will want.
One other point, it is a pattern
in US presidential politics
and almost always
President X is succeeded
by President X plus 1 who is the
opposite on almost all fronts.
You have George W. Bush
after Bill Clinton.
You have Bill Clinton
after George HW Bush.
You have Obama after
George W. Bush.
You got Trump.
So I think somebody
different from Trump
will be the next person.
So mainly while we wait
to see what the linkage is
from the local to
the national, we
do everything we can
locally to prepare
the mood of the country.
AUDIENCE: You talk
a lot about how
the national rhetoric
differs from what's
happening on the local scene.
And a lot of that
national rhetoric
is coming from the
national media.
What can the national
media do better
to give more of a realistic
or nuanced look at what's
happening on a local level?
And then also how can we, as a
society, better support what's
going on the local
level, journalism,
to kind of create more
of a nuanced dialogue
about what's going on?
JAMES FALLOWS: This is
such an important point.
And if only you
all were associated
with some major technology
company that has--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES FALLOWS: Yes.
It is of first order importance.
There's never been
a time in history
where we would think
of as serious news.
That is coverage of state
houses or international affairs
or all the rest.
There's never been
a time when that
has been a viable
self-sustaining business.
It always has had to attach
itself to some other host body,
whether it was the bundled
news packages of yesteryear.
When I was a kid in
Redlands, "The LA Times"
was 800 pages a
day, because it was
the only newspaper you could
get, or network TV or whatever.
And the history of
modern journalism
is continued death of the host
body and moving on to something
new.
Google and Facebook
together have
been agents of eliminating the
host body of the last 20 years,
of destroying the
advertising model that
kept journalism going.
And that is not anybody's
fault. But it's the reality.
And as journalism struggles
to find its next host body,
it is of really
central importance
that the organizations
and people
who were agents of
this transition help
think about its
consequences and solutions.
One reason I have admired
Google over the years,
including when we
were living in China
and Google was standing
up in the right ways, is I
think the people-- the
leadership of Google
has generally been conscious
of both the negative as well
as the positive effects of the
revolution it is engendering.
So I think that
if you're working
with Google News, its
important that you
be part of the experimentation
with journalistic institutions
to see how the new
model can emerge.
Also I think individual
rich people, from Google
and other tech companies, have
a civic and historic obligation
to try to shore up the public
infrastructure of this era.
To wrap up this
pitch, we look back
on the people who had sudden
fortunes 150 years ago,
whether it's Carnegie, or
Mellon, or Rockefeller,
or Ford, or Heinz,
or Frick or whatever.
We now think of them, not
just as financial barons,
but as something else.
Because they shored up
the public infrastructure
at that time with museums,
and universities, and parks,
and all the rest.
And I hope that their
counterparts now will also
recognize individual as well as
institutional responsibilities,
to help build up the
public infrastructure.
The cost of setting up a
Peace Corps like situation
for local reporters, it would
be trivially inexpensive,
like a teach-for-America
for our local journalists.
I know Google is doing
some of those things.
But more and more that would
make an enormous difference
to find ways for young people
to go out there to Fresno,
to Spokane, and all the rest.
So that's my pitch.
DEBORAH FALLOW: I agree.
And you can tell
that you have hit
two of the themes that are
most important in Jim's heart.
So, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Several years ago,
the Harvard political scientist,
Robert Putnam, wrote a book
called "Bowling Alone."
And the main theme of
that book was the decline
of civil society in
the United States,
basically the lack
of group engagement,
basically anomie in
towns across the country,
people not in fact doing
things together so much
and isolating themselves.
He wrote a follow-up
book a couple of years
ago where he went back
to his own high school
in northern Ohio, his own
town, his own hometown,
and found increasing
segregation,
increasing economic inequality
there, and again just divisions
that according to him
did not really exist
when he was a younger person.
Now you're coming along.
It sounds like you're
writing a story that's
really the complete opposite
of what Putnam found.
And I'm just curious
about how you
see your work in the context
of what Putnam found.
Basically, was Putnam wrong
or was he kind of right
and we still see some of that,
but what you're really finding
is just a breaking
out of that pattern?
JAMES FALLOWS: I think closest
to the last possibility
you were mentioning.
So we know Robert Putnam, of
course respect Robert Putnam.
We've debated these
issues with him.
And I think it's a
combination of we're
seeing something several
years later after he wrote.
And we're seeing it in a
different kind of reportage.
So let's stipulate.
And we're also seeing
about kinds of connections
that he left out of
his description, which
I'll illustrate for
second with Dodge City.
So of course it is the case that
as in the original Gilded Age,
there are increasing
economic extremes.
And that is a genuine
problem to deal with
and that federal
policy is making
worse now, rather than better
with the new tax policy,
et cetera.
So those compared with white
society in the '50s and '60s,
it is more polarized
than it was then.
The two counters
I would offer is
that while the bowling
leagues of northern Ohio,
where Deb is also from,
maybe different from when
Robert Putnam was a kid, we
saw two different things that
were coming up.
The maker spaces
are a different kind
of alliance from
the bowling leagues,
and just the craft brewery
movement, no kidding,
is becoming like bowling
leagues of these days, where
it was really spreading
all over the place.
I think it's also the case
that recognizing that race
is the fundamental American
crisis and problem compared
with the America Putnam is
writing about 50 years ago,
it is less separated
than it was.
And a lot of the stories
we're giving in the Midwest,
in Dodge City, and
Garden City, Kansas,
in Erie, Pennsylvania which is
Rust Belt rather the Midwest,
in Sioux Falls South
Dakota; are of white society
being much more connected
with Latino and black society
and refugee society than
was the case 50 years ago.
So I think the problems
of polarization are real.
But I think it's a more
complicated situation
than you would think, just by
the decline of bowling leagues.
Bowling leagues in
Ohio may be down.
Lots of other things are up.
And can you tell the brief
story of the ROTC student
in Sioux Falls from Somalia?
DEBORAH FALLOW: I was going
to tell the brief story
of the kids in San Bernardino.
JAMES FALLOWS: Yeah.
DEBORAH FALLOW:
Which is an example
of a rising up of civic groups
with a direction and a purpose.
San Bernardino is a
really troubled town.
And the kids who grew up there--
let's call them 30-year-olds,
plus or minus five years--
whom we met and
spent a lot of time
with, are so tired of
people nay-saying their town
and feel that they have an
opportunity and an obligation
to make things
better in that town.
So they got together.
They were primarily artists.
And they formed a
little group, which
Americans are great at doing.
They're forming new
groups, not bowling groups,
but other kinds of groups.
And the purpose of what these
kids did was the end of it
was to bring into the
mind-share of high school kids
the importance of voting.
And the way they got there
was a kind of pied piper
movement starting with
cleaning up the parks.
And they eventually,
as artists, they'd
draw murals instead of
graffiti and bad graffiti.
They'd draw nice graffiti.
And they eventually had groups
of young kids following them
around.
And then they would have
fairs and festivals that
were based around
music, and kind
of earning the goodwill of
the young people in the town,
and then made a video
very age appropriate
that they could take
into the high schools
to start to imprint on them
the importance of-- you
want to get to the end of
this, you've got to vote.
And you've got to understand
your civic responsibility
there.
So it's like what do
you call that group?
I mean they say we are
not an organization.
We are a movement.
And we saw many examples of
similar kinds of things, where
people would get
together for some purpose
and banding together.
So it's not a bowling league.
But it is a group with a
purpose of doing something.
JAMES FALLOWS: We could give you
a million more illustrations,
but I won't.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When I was
looking at the map,
I wasn't going to
bring up St. Louis.
And then you did.
But looking at that and
hearing your stories,
I'm hearing a lot of
places where there's
at least some chances
for central kind
of governmental decisions.
Many of these are
small towns, where
it sounds like most of
the people live in a place
where they can contribute to
the same city government who
can make big decisions.
My history growing
up in St. Louis
was of a region that had a
real trouble hanging together.
Decisions basically
got arbitraged
through a state
government that was also
worried about rural issues.
It was worried about
other cities in the state.
And so the ability of two people
who maybe lived a mile away
from each other,
there was no one
to go to, accept a
governor who was maybe
thinking about a presidential
run at some point,
to bind them together.
And I was curious
if there were places
where you saw more of that
regional-- several cities
in a region that were
able to come together
without having to necessarily
depend on state government.
JAMES FALLOWS: That
is interesting.
We saw a number of places where
arbitrary political boundaries
were a really
significant factor.
And I think Erie,
Pennsylvania is
one of the most important ones.
I don't know if any
of you are from Erie.
It looks at first glance
like sort of this nightmare
scape of industrial
decline, with all
these rotted-out
industrial buildings,
and then a GE plant
that is closing down.
But at the same time, the
people in their 20s and 30s
have a really active
startup up culture there.
But Erie is handicapped by the
balkanization of Pennsylvania
school district funding,
where Pennsylvania
has five times as many
administrative units
as the state of California
does, with many fewer people.
And it means that there's a
real financing squeeze on Erie,
and everybody moves
to the suburbs.
And there are things like that.
We were in Kansas
City 10 days ago.
Kansas City, Missouri/Kansas
with all of its straddles.
The places where we probably
saw the most effective--
I can tell you a place
that is aspiring to it,
in inland Southern California
where San Bernardino, really
troubled Redlands, small and
more successful; and Riverside,
large and more
successful; are trying
to find some sort of
pan-regional Inland empire
consciousness.
They're divided by a county line
there, San Bernardino County
versus Riverside County.
I think western Kansas
and northern Mississippi,
of course.
DEBORAH FALLOW: Yeah,
northern Mississippi.
In different segments,
like in Clovis and Fresno,
which are in separate
counties, they
came together on the schools
and on some school issues, which
everybody thought
couldn't happen.
In--
JAMES FALLOWS: In
central Oregon.
DEBORAH FALLOW: That's true.
JAMES FALLOWS: So
to interrupt there,
around Bend, which is now--
so Bend is now famous
as this resort site.
20 years ago it had the
highest unemployment rate
in the country, or 25 years ago.
But at some recent time,
because of the timber industry,
and in central Oregon there
was no four-year university.
So a number of
towns and counties
there worked together on
the Central Oregon Community
College, which was--
DEBORAH FALLOW: And the Golden
Triangle of Mississippi,
which--
JAMES FALLOWS: Yeah, so we
have a long chapter there
about the cities of West
Point, Columbus and Starkville,
Mississippi; which were
in three separate counties
in Mississippi.
But they have a real
coordinated effort
where they brought in
advanced manufacturing
and have been in a
quite impressive ascent.
DEBORAH FALLOW: And
Erie is definitely
talking about that too.
They are saying, we need to
look out a little bit, not just
our little town,
into regionalisms.
JAMES FALLOWS: And
greater Columbus,
Ohio too; so it's an important
point that people are trying
to cope with in different ways.
AUDIENCE: When you first
came to a town or city, what
are some of the more
surprising indicators
of either civic
health or dysfunction
that you found to be
consistently reliable?
JAMES FALLOWS:
Does somebody have
a copy of this book I
might borrow for a moment?
Most of this book is
written just as narrative.
Here's what we saw
in Sioux Falls.
Oh, we have an intro and outro.
And there's the last
part of it is called 10
and 1/2 signs of civic success.
These are the things we
learned along the way.
And most of them are
high road, for example,
that we would
always ask somebody,
who makes things go here.
And all that mattered is
that there was an answer.
And the answer in
Charleston, West Virginia
was a country music singer named
Larry Gross who some of you
may know.
He has a program
called "Mountain Stage"
on Public Radio, which has
been a fundamental fact
in Charleston, West Virginia.
And in Eastport, Maine it
was Captain Bob Peacock
and Linda Godfrey, and
some of the others.
So is there a local patriot?
Is there a local story?
Do people understand
where the city
is on the ascent of
mankind type of chart
and why the things
we're doing now
will have benefits
in the future?
But I say there are
10 and 1/2 signs.
The half sign is, is
there a craft brewery?
Because a craft
brewery has become
a genuine source of employment.
It's a sign of a certain
kind of entrepreneur,
a certain kind of
customer, and a way
in which the downtown
will be expanded
by bringing new areas into you.
But the end of the book is 10
and 1/2 signs of civic success.
So you can see it all there.
AUDIENCE: Very excited
about the prospects
of us progressing through
this poisoned atmosphere.
But I'm wondering the
flip side of the coin,
nothing's inevitable.
So what would it look like
if that didn't happen?
Because it feels as if the whole
administration that's there
is getting thinner
and thinner and just
isn't enough to actually
support long-term poison.
But I don't want to get
my hopes too high up.
JAMES FALLOWS: This is a
whole separate topic, which
we can talk about offline.
I think you will
see "The Atlantic"
going into this with
100 articles a day
about the mechanics of
the current struggle.
I think it would be better
if we had a functioning
national government.
And I think we will ultimately.
Because there's things that
only a national government can
do from environmental standards
to other kinds of standards
that hold the country together.
I think the alternative
is having California
be more and more on its own, and
Texas more and more on its own.
And that would be
OK in various ways.
But I think I'd
rather than speculate
on how bad things might look
20 or 30 years from now, think
about making sure people get out
to vote in the next few months
and that they experiment
locally to provide the fodder
for the next wave of renewal.
So with that, I think
we come back to center,
and thank you all.
Thank you all for
coming, very much.
[APPLAUSE]